vamos a resolver este problema que está
bien interesante es un problema de
perímetro de la american invitational
mathematics examination del año 2000 el
problema dice lo siguiente el diagrama
muestra un rectángulo que ha sido
dividido en nueve cuadrados que no se
enciman ahí tenemos 123456789 cuadrados
ok
luego dado que el largo y la altura del
rectángulo son enteros positivos con
máximo común divisor igual a uno
determina el perímetro del rectángulo
entonces esto de que el largo y la
altura tengan máximo común divisor o
igual a uno quiere decir que no hay
ningún entero que los divida o sea que
cuando nos fijamos en la fracción que
forman es una fracción que no se puede
simplificar por ejemplo si tuviéramos un
rectángulo de lados no se digamos 5 y 15
entonces este rectángulo no cumple con
lo que dicen porque el 5 divide a 5 y
divide a 15 la fracción 5 entre 15 se
puede simplificar entonces el rectángulo
que más bien deberíamos tener es el
rectángulo de la 2 1 y 3 si porque
tienen la misma proporción 5 a 15 1 a 3
es lo mismo pero aquí ningún entero
divide
y a3 al mismo tiempo bueno entonces esta
es la idea tenemos que determinar el
perímetro si quieres puedes ahorita
detener el vídeo para pensarlo por tu
cuenta
ahorita ya voy a empezar a resolverlo va
ok bueno para pensar en cómo resolver
este problema vamos a empezar con este
cuadrado central vamos a ponerle algún
valor a su lado no sabemos cuánto es
pero digamos que es x conociendo el lado
de este cuadrado podemos conocer su
largo y su alto porque los cuatro lados
son iguales para ahora tan solo con esto
no podemos continuar necesitamos ponerle
algún valor a otro lado de los cuadrados
entonces vayamos con el siguiente más
chiquito con este de acá y vamos a poner
que el alto o largo o lado pues es un
cuadrado de este cuadrado es igual a ye
vale entonces tenemos que es un cuadrado
del lado y yo digo que con esta
información ya podemos determinar todos
los lados de los cuadrados porque
observa si queremos calcular el lado de
este cuadrado basta sumar este lado con
este lado sería x + y entonces ahora
esto sería un cuadrado del lado x más
así que lo voy a apuntar aquí adentro
a lo mejor no es una anotación no es una
anotación muy usual para poner el lado
de un cuadrado pero va a ser pues muy
limpios y para seguir apuntando los
demás lados bueno vamos ahora este
cuadrado de acá para este cuadrado
tenemos que sumar este alto con este
alto pero sabemos que este es x más y
que éste es x entonces aquí sería 2 x
más y vale más y muy bien vamos con el
cuadrado de aquí arriba tenemos que
sumar 2 x más que es este lado con x más
que este lado de acá nos queda igual a 3
x más 2 2 y con esto podemos irnos a la
izquierda
aquí tenemos 3 x + 2 con 2 x más
entonces nos quedaría igual a 5 x 5 x +
3g + 3g y vamos haciendo progreso verdad
cada vez sabemos más medidas de lados
ahora vamos con este de aquí abajo
observa que este cuadrado no está
formado por dos lados sino por tres hay
que tener cuidado con esta x que sigue
participando vale entonces ahora
y da la medida de este cuadrado el lado
de este cuadrado sería 5 x 2 x x sea 8 x
+ 3g más 3
es igual a 4 4 oye muy bien ahora vamos
con este de acá también tiene tres lados
este este y este y aquí tenemos que la
altura sería 3 x + x o sea 4x y ahora
sumamos las dos yemas que es igual a 4 y
ya casi terminamos vamos con este
cuadrado de aquí abajo el largo tiene 4
x 4 x y además tiene 4 yemas y que sería
igual a 5 y más 58 muy bien entonces ya
tenemos los lados de los 9 cuadrados con
estos lados de los 9 cuadrados podemos
encontrar las dimensiones del rectángulo
recordemos que tenemos un rectángulo
verdad un rectángulo vamos a calcular
las entonces de este lado tenemos 5 x
más 8 x que sería igual a 13
+ 3g 4g que sería igual a 7 y 7 y ahora
déjame calcular la altura pero de este
lado debería dar lo mismo verdad porque
es un rectángulo pero a lo mejor nos
encontramos con una sorpresa entonces de
este lado tenemos 4 x más 4 x o sea
igual a 8 x 8 x ya eso tenemos que sumar
4 ya con 5 y eso de ahí es igual a 9 y
observa entonces tenemos que por un lado
la altura es 13 x 13 x + 7 y + 7 y pero
por otro lado es 8 x + 9 y pero como es
un rectángulo esto tiene que ser igual a
esto y eso nos da una restricción verdad
nos da una igualdad que dice lo
siguiente 3 x + 7 es igual a 8 x 8 x + 9
y 9 y déjame intentar simplificar esto
un poco pasando las x de un lado y las
yes de otro lado entonces voy a pasar
este 8x restando nos queda 5 x es igual
a y este 7 yo lo voy a pasar restando
o sea voy a restar 710 de ambos lados
entonces 5x es igual a 2 y 2 muy bien y
de aquí obtenemos la relación x x es
igual a dos quintos de dividiendo a
ambos lados de esta igualdad entre 5 muy
bien vamos a ver si obtenemos una
restricción similar para el largo vamos
a ver cuánto nos queda aquí sería 5 x 3
x 4 x son 12 x entonces aquí tenemos 12
x ya eso tenemos que sumar tres más dos
más cuatro y tenemos que sumar nueve y
entonces el largo es 12 x + 9 y vamos a
ver qué pasa abajo tenemos 8 x 4x que
también es 12 x y a eso hay que sumar 4
yemas 5 g que también es 99 y entonces
en realidad esto no nos da ninguna otra
restricción verdad este tiene que ser
igual a este pero pues claro que lo son
porque miden exactamente lo mismo
entonces al parecer tenemos que resolver
el problema a partir de esta información
vamos a ver qué más nos dicen
dicen además que son que el largo y la
altura son enteros positivos con máximo
común divisor igual a 1 que sucedería si
xy si tuvieran un divisor en común bueno
si algo divide a equis y allí entonces
dividiría a 13 x + 7 y verdad porque
divide a esta parte y a esta parte y de
manera similar
si pues pues o sea se divide a xy divide
a ye dividiría a esta expresión entonces
es imposible que haya un divisor común
de x y porque si no ese divisor común
sería un divisor común de los lados del
rectángulo contradiciendo que el máximo
común divisor es igual a 1 bueno eso de
qué nos sirve regresando a esta igualdad
tenemos que x pues casi casi es un
múltiplo de y entonces parece ser que es
casi imposible evitar que el máximo
común divisor sea más bien lograr que el
máximo común divisor sea igual a 1 como
es la única forma en la cual podemos
salvar esto pues justo poniendo h con un
valor que se cancele con este 5 para que
ese valor no aparezca en la expresión de
x
bueno si estoy diciendo algo muy
complicado pero básicamente estoy
sugiriendo que debemos intentar con
igual a 5 ya igual a 5 es un muy buen
valor para intentar porque el 5 se
cancelaría con este 5 con este
denominador y entonces ya no tendrían
ningún múltiplo en común vamos a ver qué
sucede vamos a ver si éste llegó a las 5
funciona si ya es igual a 5 entonces x
sería igual a 2 verdad sustituyendo aquí
ya igual a 5 aquí tenemos 5 se cancela y
x es igual a 2 y que nos quedarían los
lados
bueno pues 13 x sería igual a 26 26 para
eso tendríamos que sumar 7 y 7 por 5 es
35 entonces este lado sería 26 35 o sea
61 tendríamos que este lado es 61 y acá
tendríamos 12 x 12 x sería igual a 24 24
sumado con 9 y 9 por 5 es 45 entonces
aquí tendríamos que sumar 45 y de este
lado nos quedaría 24 45 que es igual
69 69 y esto está excelente porque 61 y
69 son números con máximo común divisor
igual a 1 puedes verificar que que no
hay ningún número que divida a ambos al
mismo tiempo vale entonces eso está
fantástico ya igual a 5 funciona
entonces las medidas de los lados son 61
y 69 y ya casi acabamos ya nada más
tenemos que encontrar el perímetro
verdad eso es lo que nos pedían desde el
principio
entonces el perímetro sería igual a
sumar la longitud de los cuatro lados
entonces tendríamos que hacer 61 más 69
más 61 más 69 y eso cuánto nos queda
pues 61 69 60 y 60 son 120 1 y 9 son 10
entonces aquí son 130 y acá tenemos
otros 130 130
de esta forma déjame ponerlo con un
color brillante tenemos que el perímetro
del rectángulo es igual a 260 260 y
entonces no fue un problema tan
espantoso vale el gran chiste del
problema fue
empezar desde adentro e ir calculando
los lados tanto de los cuadrados como
del rectángulo en términos de estos
pequeños lados que propusimos al inicio
bueno le voy a dejar hasta aquí nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo